ancient egypt is a land of mystery in
many ways
a civilization removed from us by
thousands of years at least in some ways
and yet one that we know quite a lot
about thanks to archaeology and
historical scholarship but at the same
time there are of course a lot of things
about which we are still in the dark
there are nuances to the culture life
and religion of the ancient egyptians
that are still being discovered the
religion of ancient egypt is familiar to
many we all know the great gods like ra
osiris and amun and some of the mythical
stories surrounding them by all accounts
with the exception of the revolution of
akhenaten in the amarna period egypt's
religion can be categorized as a
polytheistic one
they believed in many different deities
who all had different roles to play
but what if there's more to this story
are there traces of a one
all-encompassing absolute god in ancient
egypt and if so what does that mean for
our understanding of their religion
[Laughter]
[Applause]
when we talk about religions of the
world we often divide them into these
simplistic categories monotheism versus
polytheism for example and while this
can be helpful to get a general idea of
their characteristics this often
simplifies things quite a lot monotheism
the belief in a single omnipotent god
seems like the diametrically opposite
concept to polytheism which is belief in
many different gods and in abstract
conceptual terms this may be true but in
historical reality the distinctions
haven't always been as clear as you
might think many of the monotheistic
traditions especially in antiquity often
accepted lesser divine beings under god
who did his bidding and in many
polytheistic religions we often see the
concept of a single absolute divinity
standing above the pantheon of deities
in hinduism there are many gods and
goddesses as we all know but in the
vedic tradition of hinduism there is
also the concept of brahman a singular
divine reality or principle often
referred to as the lord in singular of
which the different deities are only
manifestations and in shaivism shiva
plays a similar role as the absolute
divine principle in the religion of
ancient greece there were many gods of
olympus
but also often referenced to ho theos
the god in the singular referring to the
highest god zeus who held the world in
his hands and stood above the other gods
and of course in the philosophical
tradition there is also talk about the
platonic one or the good and the prime
mover or unmoved mover of aristotle for
example in the religion of the aztecs in
mesoamerica they had the concept of teot
a pantheistic adjacent concept denoting
the ultimate divine reality at the
essence and as the creating force of all
things in the world including the other
gods and in ancient arabia there appears
to have been the concept of a high god
which created the world and stands above
other lesser deities and which was
referred to as al-ilah or allah
so as you can see the theologies of
polytheisms are often a lot more
complicated than you might think and
often they aren't as far removed from
monotheistic concepts as we tend to
believe either so then the question
arises what about egypt is there a
concept of a one absolute god in ancient
egyptian theology well this has actually
been quite a debate among scholars
during the 20th century the egyptologist
eric hornung argued in his book
conceptions of god in ancient egypt that
such a concept does not exist in the
egyptian tradition but later another
egyptologist john osman countered by
arguing in his book the search for god
in ancient egypt that yes actually we do
find such a concept so let's explore
some of the arguments for the concept of
a one god in ancient egypt and look at
some of these suggestive evidence first
of all if we look at works produced very
late in egypt's history even after the
fall of the pharonic civilization there
are some tantalizing clues
primarily in the hermetic literature
such as in the famous corpus hermeticum
probably composed in alexandria in the
first few centuries a.d the idea of a
singular god is all-pervading
referred to as god or the father this
divinity is all-embracing one and part
of a monistic world view god is
everything that is
these works were produced in egypt as i
said but this was an egypt that had been
under hellenistic and roman influence
for many centuries at that point and
many of its ideas clearly come from a
greek intellectual tradition
but could this concept of the one god in
the hermetica have a direct line back
into earlier periods of egyptian
theology
for that of course we need to rewind the
clock now first of all it should be
stated that the religion of ancient
egypt was unequivocally polytheistic
with the exception of the amarna period
this is an inescapable truth about this
tradition
the entire religious cult revolved
around the deities of the pantheon the
gods were worshiped individually in the
cultic sense through their embodiment in
the statues and in a cosmic sense as the
different natural phenomena in the world
not symbolically but literally ra the
sun god was the sun the entire cosmos
was a divine display every natural
phenomenon being the very real presence
of the gods in the world
abstract forces that could also be
localized in the cultic statues and thus
worshiped through rituals performed by
priests the gods were also localized as
associated with cities or regions so
thebes or wasset was the city of amun
for example and memphis was the city of
tah the myths about the gods served as
accounts of the world's creation and as
archetypes to be mirrored or performed
in their religious rituals
in all ways conceivable to the people of
ancient egypt their religion was one
that involved many different gods
not only were these gods worshiped
individually but as jan asman argues in
his book the entire worship of an
individual god was in connection to that
god's relationship with the other
deities of the pantheon the world of the
egyptians was one of diversity and
plurality personified by the variety of
the gods themselves perhaps the most
central concept for this religious
worldview was that of ma'at meaning
something like order the order of the
cosmos or universe itself something that
had to be maintained by appeasing the
different gods through ritual and
through the king's duty to maintain
social justice and order so we're not
looking for some original monotheism
here as many early christian
egyptologists did and none of this
should the very real fact of the
plurality of divinity in ancient egypt
be neglected
with that said like in many other
polytheistic religions as we've seen the
situation can also be a bit more complex
than this and in relation to this
plurality we sometimes do find pretty
clear references to the concept of god
in the singular sometimes in the period
of the middle kingdom but especially
during the new kingdom period jan osman
makes a distinction in his book between
what he calls implicit theology and
explicit theology
implicit theology means theology that is
implicit in the polytheistic ritual cult
the dominated egyptian religion while
explicit theology is a separate category
of theological speculation that in some
ways runs parallel to it and gives birth
to theological expressions that are
quite unique and this becomes apparent
especially in the new kingdom called
implicit and explicit theology thus
originally had entirely different themes
and referred to entirely different
horizons of the experience of the world
implicit theology had nothing to do with
the beginning and end of time or with
the justification for the world and of
evil rather it revolved around sacred
activities as they were carried out in
the cult through which it interpreted
cosmic reality and in terms of which it
made an account of the divine
this implicit theology of the cult is
the kind that is unalterably
polytheistic being caught up in the
multiplicity of the divine realm
explicit theology however opened up for
other kinds of ideas and conceptions of
the divine aspects that were more
unitive but to begin this exploration
paradoxically we're going to begin by
looking at a creation myth something
that is usually associated with what
john osman calls implicit theology in
the so-called creation myth of
heliopolis which we find in some of the
earliest pyramid texts the creation of
the world is conceived of as originating
in the god atom
autumn is the one who came into being by
himself in pre-existence and who then
produces the first gods shu air and
tefnut fire through self-fertilization
or even ejaculation
these gods then produce further gods all
of whom eventually become the bases for
the cosmos the name autumn means both
something like to be everything and to
be nothing as well as to be finished he
is the all from which everything comes
into being
quote the cosmos emanated from autumn
autumn turned himself into the cosmos
this is quite a complex philosophical
concept that definitely reaches
speculation beyond a simple implicit
conceptualization of cultic rituals
autumn is the all of non-existence from
which all things come and which all
things are
he emanates the other gods and thus the
cosmos by creating them from himself
in other words he is the other gods and
he is the cosmos in some way
he is everything and he is nothing
this seems to at least indicate
something close to what we are looking
for the idea of an absolute divinity
that can even be conceptualized as
standing above the other gods and this
autumn theology becomes even more
explicit during the middle kingdom
in coffin text from this period meant to
help a deceased in the afterlife we
witnessed some profound developments
from the more mythical account to one of
more explicit theology here the children
of atom shu and tefnut are identified
with life and ma'at and the text makes
it clear that we are not really talking
about separate gods but a unity of three
concepts quote when i was alone in noon
inert they were already with me
what follows is a poetic expression of
creation as an awakening or coming into
consciousness of the all lord or autumn
and the role that shu and tevnet play in
that as caught he was one and became
three
in another section that issuer life
himself who speaks referring to autumn
quote he created me in his heart he made
me out of his radiant power he was
pregnant with me in his nose i emerged
from his nostrils in other words here
shoe or life becomes the very breath of
autumn the creator god or the all from
which all things emerge as the breath of
god he is in a way identical to him
emphasizing that unity between them and
further states quote when he sent me to
this earth the isle of fire and when i
became osiris the son of gibb
shu becomes osiris so here is an even
more explicit reference to the idea that
the gods are really one and the same
they all come from the all lord whose
breath shu gives life to all things a
breath that also in the cosmic sense
manifests as the actual wind or air that
we experience
remember shoe is originally the god of
air or wind these are quite profound and
complex ideas as you can tell but we are
still kind of in the realm of mythology
even if the gods in this later
expression especially becomes more
abstract and are removed somewhat from
their mythological
roots the language is essentially still
polytheistic so to say but at the same
time during the middle kingdom we see
other evidence in non-religious
literature for example these so-called
instructions collections of wisdom
literature in which the language more
clearly develops from one of gods to god
in the singular
in the instruction for king medicare
likely a middle kingdom text there is a
section at the end that is especially
interesting for our purposes where it
says quote
one generation of mortals follow another
but god the all-knowing has concealed
himself
there is none who can resist the might
of the lord of the hand for it is he who
can restrain all of the eyes can see
god must be revered he who moves upon
his unchanging path whose images are
made of costly stone and fashioned from
copper shepherd the people the cattle of
god
for it is for their sake that he created
heaven and earth he still the raging of
the waters and created the wind so that
their nostrils might live
they are his images who came forth from
his body and it is for their sake that
he rises in the sky and the text goes on
like that for a while but i don't need
to quote anymore for us to see that we
are seeing quite a new expression of
devotion and theology here one that is
not talking about a god among other gods
even seemingly a god especially exalted
but as god in the singular god who
creates and sustains all things god in
the form of a single absolute divinity
and these examples from the middle
kingdom are only a foretaste or perhaps
the earliest indications of a
development that would really flourish
and culminate during the new kingdom
especially in the 18th and 19th
dynasties the new kingdom is an
incredibly vibrant period in terms of
religious and intellectual developments
and a lot is taking place here
first of all and in connection to the
official capital becoming located in
thebes or wasset the god associated with
that locale amun became especially
prominent during this period
over the course of the 18th dynasty amon
became the highest and most important
god especially in the combined form of
amun ra in which he became identified
with the sun god this god came to have a
very exalted place in egyptian religion
and it is with this that we see a
continuation of the theological
speculation and expression that had
begun in the middle kingdom a lot of
references to amun ra take the form of
god in the singular and being considered
the god who has created all things
not only this but an entirely new
conception of god's very nature emerges
in the cult of amundra
he was no longer a distant theory that
could only be reached through the cults
or talked about in terms of mythical
accounts
now amun ra was a god with a will who
could intervene in history and interact
with the god in a different way he was a
personal god who was present to every
individual and could be experienced by a
court placing god in one's heart
court
one who listens to the entreaty of one
in distress gracious to one who calls to
him who saves the timarus from the hand
of the violent who pronounces justice
between the poor and the rich lord of
cognition on whose lips is created word
for whose sake the nile inundation comes
the lord of affection the great of love
when he comes humankind lives he who
grants a clear road to every ayah that
was created in noon
whose radiance allows it to become light
over whose beauty the gods rejoice at
the side of whom their hearts quicken
the sun god had always played a major
role in the polytheistic religion of
egypt but here his world is exalted
above anything before he is the one who
quote devises everything that is the god
who through his will and speech creates
all the gods and all of reality it is he
who quote creates what is created who
speaks and the gods come into being this
is a significant development and one
that would have important consequences
later on
john osman writes quotes as god of life
our moon is a god who speaks a god who
speaks and hears what is right who
imparts instructions who pronounces
judgments who discerns and decides a god
of consciousness and convictions and
thus of ethics a personal god and thus a
god of personal devotion and decision
in this sense as a distinct personal god
of life defined by speech will and
consciousness and as ethical authority
amun was a new god and his worship was a
new religion his role as the sun would
prove especially fruitful for
theological speculation and this
tendency eventually developed into what
scholars often call the new solar
theology which placed the sun at the
very center of religious worship and in
many places almost did away with
mythological accounts entirely the sun
god in the form of
as well as other names and forms was the
god for pharaohs like amenhotep iii as
many of us know it is also this that
leads to the incredibly fascinating
revolution of akhenaten who turned
egyptian religion upside down by
creating a kind of monotheistic religion
centered on the god aten or the sun disk
the so-called amarna period of akhenaten
is covered fully in a previous episode
which you can watch but basically puts
he conceived of the sun disk arten and
its light as the only god and even
suppress the worship of other gods
entirely especially our moon this was a
radical change in many ways but we can
also see it as a development from the
earlier theological tendencies that we
have discussed
akhenaten simply took these ideas to
their most extreme conclusion this event
was traumatic for many egyptians and the
movement of akhenaten didn't really
survive past his own death
after he died it basically was abandoned
eventually entirely
but just because his religion
disappeared that doesn't mean that
all earlier theological developments
disappeared also or indeed that his
revolution didn't have an effect on
later
religious life in egypt it definitely
did because in the following 19th
dynasty we see perhaps the culmination
and high points of the so-called
explicit theology that had developed
from the middle kingdom period not only
in the sense that expressions about the
personal god reach its combination which
it does
during the ram aside period the idea
that the individual can have a personal
relationship with god became a central
mode of piety for farmers as well as for
kings quote the son of him who does not
recognize you sets amun but he who
recognizes you says it has risen in the
forecourt
he who attacks you is in darkness even
when the whole land is in light but he
replaces you in his heart though his son
has risen
god here in the form of a moon can be
recognized by the individual and quote
placed in the heart
this is probably a response to the
amarna period in which all gods
especially amun were persecuted in favor
of the aton
the cult of amun was forbidden which
restricted people from being able to
worship the god in the traditional ways
through the temples for example so
instead they developed an inner devotion
god was worshiped in secrets in the
heart of the devotee
and this way of relating to god
continued into the 19th dynasty and
beyond but secondly it is in the
ramified period that we also get
possibly the high point of theological
expression relating to the idea of a one
universal all-encompassing god of course
we should remember that after the amana
period ended the traditional
polytheistic cult was reinstated and
supported so what appears is not a
monotheism and the more strict
definition of that word such as what
akhenaten had tried to establish but
rather a more complex theology where the
unity of god and the plurality of
deities and the worlds is merged in a
grand pantheistic formulation again here
it becomes clear that the conception of
god and the singular is a very real
concept that stands above the other gods
or in which those gods are integrated
this all-encompassing god is the creator
the source of everything moral guide and
giver of life quote
life belongs to you there will be no
other who gives life to every visage you
are the light that drives off evil no i
lives that does not see you you are the
air that allows the throat to breathe
no animal lives that does without you
you are the inundation that keeps
humankind alive no face lives if you are
not in it
as you can tell the all-encompassing
nature of this divinity is radical and
formulates itself in a pantheistic way
god is everything he embodies the cosmos
quote you are the sky you are the earth
you are the netherworld you are the
water you are the air between them
god is the hidden unity which manifests
itself into the plurality of the gods
who in themselves are the different
aspects of the cosmos he is the one and
the all quote greetings you saw one who
makes himself into millions who extends
in length and breadth without bounds
equipped power that created itself you
ray a serpent with huge flame rich in
magic mysterious of form hidden bar to
whom reverence is shown
this is a universal god that exists in
tandem with the many deities of the
egyptian pantheon the polytheistic cults
continued and remained the main form of
religious expression in egypt but
alongside this there was now a clear
conception that beyond this plurality of
manifestation there was a single divine
force of which these diverse gods were
parts or aspects or manifestations
perhaps this is a theology which quotes
explains the various deities as aspects
names forms of manifestation in brief as
imminent refractions of the transcendent
unity of the single god
sometimes this divinity could be
especially associated with a particular
god in the new kingdom it was often amun
the hidden one
in later antiquity was sometimes the
goddess isis who took on this role but
the concept remains the same as amun god
is the hidden one the primordial
transcendent unity but as the other
deities god is the cosmos in its vast
plurality he is ra the sun he is shu the
heir and so on
this exalted conception of the divine a
kind of pantheistic theology with a
single divinity at its center came to
dominate theological expression from the
19th dynasty and for the rest of the
classical egyptian civilization all the
way into the hellenic and roman periods
we continue to see these kinds of
expressions so we have seen how the
theological speculation in egypt
gradually developed from the cultic
aspects of the old kingdom through
speculation in the middle and early new
kingdom through the trauma of the omana
period to reach a fascinating conception
of the divine by the 19th dynasty and
beyond this conception of the divine
might have married well with ideas
developed in greece about whole fields
as well as philosophical speculations
regarding concepts like the one in
thinkers like plato so when we read text
from late antiquity like the corpus
hermeticum composed in egypt and find
expressions of a single god at the
essence of reality we can perhaps see a
continuity in terms of where these ideas
come from not only from greek
philosophical speculation but also from
a long tradition of theology in native
egypt which conceived of the divine in a
similar way
religion in ancient egypt is of course a
very complex topic and there are many
voices in the scholarship not all of
whom agree on these questions this has
been one of those episodes that is
especially indebted to and based on the
work of a single scholar or historian
the egyptologist john osman particularly
as expressed in his book the search for
god in ancient egypt so if you're
interested in diving even deeper into
this topic i highly suggest you pick up
his book and read it and also i highly
suggest you look at scholarship more
generally more broadly and also consider
opinions of scholars that may differ
from what i have presented here this
episode has been one interpretation of
the sources and interpretation that
might prove problematic in light of new
evidence something that's always very
relevant when it comes to ancient egypt
of course but i think the argument is
quite convincing and it does provide a
nice continuity with the kind of
religious expressions that we find in
egypt in later antiquity so as you can
see even in egypt and in most
polytheistic traditions it is often a
lot more complex than to simply say they
believe in many different gods in
complete contrast to the concept of
monotheism these terms are of course
fuzzy and it depends on how we define
them but i think realizing these things
is a good step towards a more
comprehensive and truthful understanding
of religious history and thoughts
particularly as it pertains to the world
of ancient egypt in this case i hope you
found this episode informative and
interesting i would like to extend a
special thank you to all my patrons of
course who keep this channel going
without whom i would not be able to be
doing this so as always my deepest
heartfelt gratitude to all of you guys
you can look forward to more episodes on
ancient egypt in which we can explore
various fascinating aspects of their
religious tradition but until then i'll
see you next time
[Music]
you